anderes gesicht ungekämmt des lichtes
haar seniorin edith es wirkt sehr
zerbrechlich als sie von der anwältin
gestützt dem gerichtssaal in konstanz
betritt doch es ist unfassbar welche
horror tat man der 84 jährigen vorwirft
sie soll ihren ex mann bei lebendigem
leib verbrannt haben feuerwehrleute
retten die rentnerin am 17 januar diesen
jahres aus ihrem brennenden haus bei
konstanz in den trümmern finden die
einsatzkräfte die leiche ihres ex-mannes
johannes es laut staatsanwaltschaft soll
die tests zunächst mit einem fleisch
hammer auf ihren ex mann eingeschlagen
haben als der sich wehrte habe die 84
jährige aus der garage einen
benzinkanister geholt und johannes es in
brand gesteckt während er mit dem notruf
sprach schnell wird die seniorin
verdächtigt kommt in eine psychiatrie
dann in u haft
als motiv wird eifersucht vermutet
johannes es habe sie trotz trennung im
haus leben lassen soll jedoch eine neue
beziehung gesucht haben
zum prozessauftakt in konstanz hat edith
es die aussage verweigert